so und dann haben wir seit gestern also
eine bundes notbremse oder wie ich sie
zärtlich nenne unsere neueste kompromiss
geburt wirklich ich freue mich dass wie
machen wir das immer wieder
wochenlange debatten und am ende kommt
irgendwas teures raus was keiner
versteht und was natürlich auch gar
nicht reicht immerhin die groko selber
ist zufrieden
ich will nicht verheimlichen dass es
wenn es nach uns gegangen wäre wäre
dieses projekt schon im november auf der
tagesordnung gehabt haben das wollten
die kollegen von der union damals nicht
aber besser nie als spät besser nie als
spät schöner kann man das deutsche
pandemie management gar nicht
zusammenfassen
jetzt kommt also in gebieten mit
incidents über 100 die ausgangssperre ab
22 uhr beziehungsweise erst ab
mitternacht wenn man als einzelperson
spazieren geht oder joggt na da hat sich
wohl die mächtige nachbar lobby
durchgesetzt wie das jetzt der neue
trick als einzelpersonen mitten im
bierkasten nacht zur partien job absolut
im rahmen der notbremse und daneben
morgens um kurz nach fünf besoffen
zurück nach hause da ist alles legal
außerdem beschlossen schulen machen
dicht ab incidents 165 wie kommt man auf
so krumme zahlen wirklich würfeln da ja
noch seriös der spd mann dirk wie sagt
jetzt offen zugegeben ich zitiere
letztendlich resultiert die 165 daraus
dass am montag der durchschnittswert
aller 16 bundesländer beim incidents
wert bei ungefähr 165 lag die haben
nicht mal mehr bock sich eine halbwegs
logische begründung für irgendwas
auszudenken man als echten ganz blöder
zeitpunkt schulkind zu sein wirklich
aktuelle ifo studie deutsche kinder
verbringen pro tag drei stunden weniger
mit schulischen aktivitäten als vor
kroner
manche haben 2021 schule noch gar nicht
von innen gesehen
jakob hat nur einmal die woche online
unterricht für 30 minuten eine aktuelle
erhebung der landes eltern konferenz aus
nrw zeigt nun wie verbreitet diese
ihm ist jeder vierte schüler hat nur
einmal die woche kontakt zum lehrer
mein gott schule auf zu auf zu viele
schüler wissen schon gar nicht mehr wann
sie schwänzen sollen warum gibt es nach
über einem jahr pandemie immer noch
keinen mindeststandards für digitalen
unterricht live stream statt
arbeitsblätter whatsapp immerhin will
bundesbildungsministerin carlitscheck im
herbst eine milliarde für nachhilfe
programme ausgeben klingt gut mal zum
vergleich die kleinen niederlande nehmen
genau dafür 8,5 milliarden in die hand
von wegen bildung ist deutschlands
wichtigster rohstoff und wo ich eh schon
wieder beim warum bin warum sind
luftreiniger im klassenzimmer immer noch
kein standard
glückliche schulen kriegen wenigstens
welche gespendet das wurde vom stadtrat
untersagt dass die geräte genutzt werden
dürfen weil unklar ist ob die
stromleitung das aushalten
doch auf eine prüfung der stromleitungen
wartet er seit monaten ja der
schulleiter hätte gerne geschrieben an
der stelle aber er darf ohne
luftreiniger natürlich keine erosion
freisetzen die realität ist immer
weniger unterricht dafür hocken unsere
kinder immer länger zocken am computer
lockdown halt wenn man könnte man da
nicht pädagogisch ansetzen
hallo wer ist dein mathelehrer cooler
unfall von dem drogendealer aufgabe 1 81
kilo schwerer körper fliegt bei 230 km h
aus dem auto bereichen die flugbahn des
dealers und seine
aufprallgeschwindigkeit lösung bis heute
abend und wie immer per fax klar wie
denn sonst sie merken es gibt nach einem
mehr oder weniger verlorenen schuljahr
was echt ein skandal ist sehr reale
missstände im zusammenhang mit kindern
und corona aber das internet oder
konkreter die querdenker szene hat jetzt
einen ganz anderen aufreger entdeckt
mehr weiß tina hausten zdf spezial die
augsburger puppenkiste dreht durch und
will unsere kinder umbringen
guten abend liebe zuschauer es ist alles
noch viel schlimmer als wir gedacht
haben
rommel aus dem eis und der kleine könig
kalle wirsch arbeiten jetzt auch für big
pharma und den starts funk unsere
geliebte augsburger puppenkiste hat sich
kaufen lassen aber nicht die katze mit
dem alu hut nein die natürlich nicht er
macht keiner was vor ort
hier läuft die schlimmste linksgrüne
kinder gehirnwäsche seit der hochzeit
von ernie & bert in einem achtminütigen
propaganda machwerk für das sich leni
riefenstahl geschenkt hätte erklärt ein
gewisser doktor kaspar unseren wehrlosen
kindern assistiert vom diabolischen
erdmännchen erwin wie testen
obwohl in der verpackung ein surinam des
extraktions röhrlich und ein spender
käpsele extraktions rolle wie geil es
ist aber nicht oliver es ist ein
verbrechen und die wachen menschen da
draußen haben das auch verstanden hier
original youtube kommentare unfassbar
diese faschistische puppenkiste oder
tolle leistungen die anleitung zur
selbstverstümmelung viel spaß die ganzen
stäbchen aus der trennwand zum gehirn
raus zu operieren das ist nicht
ausgedacht ich bin wie viele kinder
haben sich schon doof gekoppelt
ja oder hier gemeinsam bringen wir eine
ganze generation in die psychiatrie oder
treiben sie in den selbstmord liebe
puppenkiste machen sie sich bitte nicht
zur seilschaft gut marionetten sind per
definition eine seilschaft in der seile
oliver nehmen sie das bitte ernst
jetzt im nachhinein wirken ja auch erst
klar wie uns die kommunisten kiste schon
seit jahrzehnten indoktriniert ich habe
zum beispiel jetzt erst diese alte szene
aus dem knopf verstanden
lukas der lokomotivführer war in
wirklichkeit schlepper und bringt ihr
den alleinreisenden minderjährigen
gefördert jim knopf nach europa mit
einer schwindenden lokomotive ich habe
das mal im internet recherchiert oliver
und wissen sie was lokomotiven können
gar nicht schwimmen und oliven presse
bettina wobei man sagen muss aus dem
schitt storm für die puppenkiste ist
inzwischen ja ein sogenannter kennen die
storm geworden also viel mehr positive
kommentare als negativ
genau und da müssen wir dringend
gegensteuern deshalb herzlich willkommen
zur wutbürger pharma kiste ich bin bill
gates und ich will dass ihr euch dieses
teststäbchen ins gehirn rammt ich habe
extra ein rasierklinge daran geklebt
damit ist noch mehr weh tut
angenommen wir hatten und ich finde du
hast immer die besten ideen
ich liebe dich knutschen und sagt euren
eltern sie sollen weiter zwangsgebühren
zahlen
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los los du
scheiße fährt